[Music]
good morning John it is December 17th
that means it is the secret project day
welcome to the 2007 nerdfighter power
project for awesome for those of you who
don't know what that means let me go
through word by word nerdfighter a
nerdfighter is a person who remember
their John is so fond of saying is on
the inside instead of bones and organs
and stuff actually made of Awesome now
we know that these nerdfighters are made
of Awesome because they do awesome
things power the nerdfighters wield
great power because they are many and
they work together to do things like
this project the project is to take over
YouTube we're taking over YouTube by
having this image be the thumbnail for
hundreds of videos videos from people
who have 50,000 subscribers and videos
from people who have 5 subscribers lots
of people are involved from oh oh I'm
gesturing far too much I must be very
excited so that's the project we're
taking over YouTube and it's a project
for awesome because every person who's
making a video in their nerdfighter
power project for awesome is promoting a
charity of their choice that they
believe reduces the amount of suck in
the world now people who know me will
assume that I will probably be
advocating for some kind of green
technology clean technology kind of
thing because that is what I do for my
day job so one would think cellulosic
ethanol paperless book readers come back
fluorescent lightbulbs maybe or solar
power reducing wasteful junk mail or
terraforming the surface of Mars
Agata lslam not really an environmental
technology but no I believe very
strongly in the power of all those
things to help make the world a better
place that's not what I'm going to talk
about today no today we talk about
kitties there can never be too much cat
on YouTube elderly that these companion
animal pets in general is a very strange
thing basically we created these animals
we bred them to be our companions and to
be useful to us cats specifically for
eating mice out of the grain Meo catches
mice in our house she doesn't eat them
no she mostly just puts them in her
mouth walks around with them and puts
them down and lays on top of them we
selectively bred them to exist so they
are in a way an extension of us and so
because we created them we have a
responsibility to every member of their
species to take care of them
unfortunately we are often not able to
do that every year there are about 30
million cats born in the United States
30 million care
there are seven cats born for every
person born in the United States every
year which is why my cause for the
nerdfighter power project for awesome is
pet population control give money to
your local humane society so that they
can take care of these animals when they
need to be taken care of and so they can
be adopted and not put the sleep and
spay neuter your cats it's cheap and
it's our responsibility there's no
reason not to okay there may be one
reason not to enough that you feel kind
of bad for cutting some particular
pieces off of certain male pets I can
understand that it's kind of no it's not
a pleasant thought but it's better for
one cat to wander around nut lists and
for all of his dozens of progeny to be
miserable in the cold because no one
loved them spay neuter adopt give money
Humane Society and now what I will ask
you to do is comment a lot on this video
and other videos with the nerdfighter
power project for awesome thumbnail and
if you would like to make a nerdfighter
power project for awesome video there's
a link over there and if you would like
to find out more about how to
participate by commenting is linked in
the sidebar or down there depending on
where you are we'll be seeding these
videos with questions that you can
answer and if you find that you can no
longer comment you have to refresh the
page enter the CAPTCHA code and then you
can comment again the more comments we
get the more ratings we get the more
favorites we get and every single video
that has the nerdfighter power project
for awesome thumbnail the better I'm
very excited about this thank you so
much to everyone who's participating you
guys all really Rock thank you so much
from brotherhood 2.0 from John and from
me we'll see you all all day long common
thing in everything and John I will see
you in your video tomorrow